hello and welcome to a video on
biochemistry and nutrition today we'll
talk about keto diet and what is the
scientific basis behind it
so keto diet is one kind of diet
composition which would be majorly fat
very low in protein and carbohydrate
fat would comprise 70 to 80 percent of
that diet there would be 20 to 25
protein and 5 to 10 percent would be
carbohydrate
now we can get our calories from three
sources namely carbohydrate
protein or fat
both carbohydrate and protein has
kind of four to five kilocalories per
gram
of caloric peak value whereas fat has
way more than that
even though fat has much more calorific
value our body is not trained to utilize
fat
it turns out that our body always
prefers to utilize carbohydrate in order
to generate energy
so body prefers glucose over fatty acids
and brain needs glucose for its
functioning and even under starved state
where brain cannot stop functioning
brain needs the steady supply of glucose
in order to function and fatty acid at
that moment of time cannot be utilized
by the brain because it cannot reach the
brain and cannot cross the blood-brain
barrier
so here is the catch
imagine this glucose is like the steady
fuel of a particular bike
now
once the steady foil is over
then it can run on reserve fuel and this
reserve will in context of brain or body
is basically ketone bodies
actually our brain can utilize ketone
bodies and ketone bodies can cross blood
brain barrier so when glucose is not
present such as when we are starving
brain can run on keto fuel
and this is how our brain keeps on going
in short
ketone bodies are like the reserve fuel
for the brain
now the question is how our body starts
to utilize fat in order to generate
energy because in keto diet we are
consuming a hell lot of fat
the question is how our body is getting
adapted to this situation
now ketogenesis
can intrinsically happen when we are
starving for a long term
let's try to understand this aspect
so when we are starving for long our
liver produces acetoacetate acetone or
meta hydroxybutyric acid all of these
are ketone bodies
now
when we are starving for long what
really happens is
our body produces ketone body or it's
kind of like a ketogenesis state
and in keto diet we are forcing our body
or training our body
to create ketone bodies generally under
normal circumstances body don't produce
ketone bodies but utilizing the keto
diet paradigm we are training our body
and
telling the body to break down fat and
make ketone bodies out of it
and that is why it's really important
now the biggest question is can keto
diet lead to weight loss and this is the
biggest question people have there in
having their minds
and it turns out there is a scientific
basis behind it little bit complicated
but it's important to understand
so let's say we are pretty slim at this
moment but we consume a lot of
carbohydrates cheesy food so what really
happens is
all of these carbohydrate-based food
would lead to production of energy
now it all boils down to calorie in
versus calorie out let's say our calorie
input is too much but we don't really
spend that calorie or we don't work out
that much due to our sedentary lifestyle
so what really happens is
glucose gets converted to acetyl coa
initially that would be channeled into
krebs cycle to generate energy
but this
atp generation or energy generation is
kind of
demand based
so when the body
demand for atp is totally done body
would not produce any more atps because
it would be kind of like a waste right
so obviously krebs cycle would not
happen
and the acetyl-coa would be channeled
into production for fatty acid
so fatty acid biosynthesis would be
favored under this kind of circumstances
when glucose level is pretty high
in a well-fed state
and the excess of fatty acid would
ultimately be deposited on the adipose
tissues and the end result is you would
become fat
now let's see what keto diet does
but before that let's understand one
hormonal regulation in terms of
uh keto diet so when we take normal diet
which is enriched in blood enriched in
glucose
then
acetyl coa carboxylase enzyme which is
key for fatty acid biosynthesis gets
activated
acetyl-coa converts into melodyne
melanoil coa and that can give rise to
fatty acid synthesis
actually this particular red limiting
enzyme exists in an inactive state or an
active state
and it can be converted from its
inactive to active state with the help
of an phosphatase enzyme
and
when glucose level is high insulin level
is also high and insulin triggers this
phosphatase enzyme ultimately
augmenting the process of
fatty acid biosynthesis so overall what
really happens that when insulin is
there
and body is under well-fed state and too
much of blood glucose is there body
converts majority of that blood glucose
into kind of like a fat fatty acid
and it would be deposited
but under
keto diet when the glucose input is
really low
acetyl coa cannot be produced from the
glucose because at the first place
glucose level is low
right
so acetyl-coa production happens
by breaking down of the fatty acid so
fatty acid gets oxidized to acetyl-coa
and this acetyl-coa is not channeled
into fatty acid biosynthesis pathway
rather it is channeled into ketone body
generation because in absence of glucose
ketone is a reserve fuel for our body
and the brain
that is why
our body starts breaking the fat and in
this process our body is trained
to break down fat or utilize the fat to
produce ketone bodies
and as the end result
what happens body do not make fat and
body learns how to
utilize the fat to generate ketone
bodies
obviously fat breakdowns happen and you
lose weight this is the mechanism behind
keto diet and weight loss
now
normal diet and keto diets are very
different right the proportion is
different
but when you transit from a normal diet
to a keto diet this transition might not
be smooth
your body might undergo some flu-like
symptoms which includes nausea vomiting
constipation diarrhea headache and many
things more and this kind of keto flu is
kind of normal because body is
undergoing a metabolic transition
body learns how to use fat as a primary
energy source instead of glucose so in
this transition state this kind of
disbalance and this kind of symptoms
does appear and it's nothing to worry
about
keto diet has multiple health benefits
starting from weight loss
increased energy and good cardiovascular
wealth
and then it has
been proven to be important for
increasing cognitive ability
lastly in order to control blood glucose
level keto diet is really important but
there are several myths associated with
keto diet like keto right is really
dangerous if you have diabetes
now it's not really true
because the ketogenic diet has actually
been
validated by american diabetic
association and it's it turns out to be
really useful for controlling blood
sugar in type 2 diabetes patient
there are
other myths like keto diet is bad for
heart because it has a lot of fat so it
might cause problem in your
cardiovascular health but it's not true
because if you have
a lot of
fat in your
circulation
it is bad because it might get deposited
on the arteries but under ketogenic
state body knows how to utilize it
so nothing would be actually deposited
on the arteries right
now in the keto diet when we consume
more fat if we can
make sure that our fat comes from very
healthy sources like salmon like olive
oils that which are enriched in
omega-3 fatty acids then it would be
really really beneficial for your
cardiovascular health
so overall ketogenesis
and ketogenic diet could be proven
useful
to improve your cardiac health and it is
known to increase good cholesterol or
hdl level
now i hope that was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
now if you want to know more about
ketogenesis or how our body utilize
ketone bodies to generate energy all the
necessary links would be provided in the
i button and the description don't
forget to like share and subscribe do
let me know in the comment whether it
was useful or not thank you